[Music]
on the chef eric bruner yang born in
taiwan at age his family moved to
california then japan and eventually
virginia as a young adult there he
played in a successful local band until
a transition to the restaurant business
in 2011 he opened washington dc's  toki
underground andes ram out next honey
asian gry 2015 he added maket a whole
asian marketplace named one of eaters 21
best new restaurants in america chef
eric brun yang welcome good morning
what's going on thanks for coming in
tell us what you brought all right so we
got five dishes we start with dessert
right so we got chocolate chip cookies
with a red miso buttercream we have a
cambodian dish called pra which is
basically pork chili fried chicken
obviously we have steam buns pork and
vegetarian and then we have kind of ram
ram  and this kind like rice pudding but
actually it's season with chinese flavor
called little ch
powder sal
spy fantastic and by the way i with
dessert may never leave it fantastic as
well i mention your varied background in
growing up taiwan virginia california
where did the love of  food come was in
one place where was my
love love trying to be as independent
as i could so as soon as i could start
working when i was 15 i just wanted to
get a job so i could have my own money i
could socialize and  at the same time i
loved being busy as busy as i could
possibly be so my first job was making
caramel popcorn at the mall and then
i and then i went you know and i did a
burger place taco place and i just kept
working as much  as i could but your mom
wanted you to be a classical pianist right
yeah for the most part it was very much
like
independent as as was doan all time was
doing sps all the time i led being i led
expressing myself so this is kind how it
evolved but you also expressed yourself
in a band i was sort of joking you could
be our saturday session and the dish all
rolled into one that's right i'm the
classic cliche like lon cook
rock with
tatto mer for any it was just really
you  know what i love about the
restaurant industry is that it doesn't
matter where you come from is that if
you just work really
hard you know the opportunities for you
to excel are always there yeah in type
you had your aha moment what was that
so  my grandfather i was raised by my mom
my grandparents in taiwan when i was
young but he passed away in 2010 and i
was spending a lot of time in that
country and for a long time being mix
asian i kind
rejected asian root that was kind  of
where i really embraced you know where i
was from and my love for brahman
essentially at the end and taip is a
very multicultural city and it's heavily
influenced by the japanese culture so it
was a really mix of you know where i've
been which  was living in japan born in
taiwan living in the us and that's how
we came up with to underground was how
to like capsule how i felt about myself
when i was in my late 20's what convince
you to open the first raman house in dc i
mean that was a pretty bold move it
was a bold move especially at the time
didn't really know how to turn it into a
restaurant but also a really good
opportunity because you know there is no
ram shops to new yorkers that's crazy
there's like ram  shops everywhere like
you mean there's no ramen shop in the
nation's capital but yeah we got lucky
and also happened to be good and that's
how we got our foot in the door you talk
and
going
we basically like a hotel with no room
open at got  the cafe people can do their
shopping i think it's just the new wave
of retail also the new wave of
restaurants well it is the dish so we
would like you to sign our dis and i'll
ask you if you can have a meal with
anyone  past present who would be that's
you know really crazy
loaded but you know my grandmother just
passed this year and get to
kid for one
mef thank you so much we appreciate itf
eric bruner yang for more on him and the
dish you can head to our  website at cbs
this morning